I like how as for place that's for the
god of donut wrap and it is it's
actually trapped because they came to
check for it they gonna bring it down
oh yes started to play a different way
and everybody else started to go he's a
one of the most talented players I know
and one of the smartest players I've
ever met not gonna be back in the face
it got me kicked me but no boots of
travel
you're number one
now take over the
thank you
Gustav s for Magnuson was born on April
1st 1992 in Sweden as the youngest as
for was often left to watch his three
older brothers play video games
remember father has always been into
decent gaming in general start with my
dad I got into it and a good stuff shut
behind me like watched me playing games
but while he was watching as for
developed a different kind of
appreciation for the games his brothers
played he was watching from the outside
analyzing how they played so that when
he finally got his turn he was ahead of
the curve
I remember when it's like five six years
old sometimes I woke up and I see the
light under the door oh my god I think
not again I opened the door and I said
good stuff
I forgot sake turn off the computer it's
still time tomorrow but as he grew older
as far as family came to realize that
his dedication to games wasn't different
than other kids dedication to sports we
discussed it and said well maybe this is
like a hockey player if you let them do
what they love and push you then maybe
this could work to be something again
but it was in Heroes of Newerth where s
4 first made a name for himself from Oh
a nice disjoint from magnet there
alongside a slew of other amateur dota 2
stocks advantage he signed with lions at
sport club and made it all the way to
the NASL season 2 finals but couldn't
attend due to visa issues
just a few months later s4 switched to
dota 2 and join team Empire during a
period of roster instability only months
after joining s were left empire to form
a new team the tough bananas which was
quickly signed by the copenhagen wolves
that is the copenhagen wolves hello way
for the camera hi mom I'm on television
I'm a great esports esports Minh but
that roster didn't find much success in
her leaving s4 to find yet another new
team this time he formed no tidehunter
alongside admiralbulldog eternalenvy
black and Kissel's after some success
black and Kissel left the team and were
replaced by lota and aki s4 didn't know
it at the time but he was finally on a
team that was set to make history
[Music]
at 3m hack winter 2012 no tidehunter
didn't drop on the match in the stage
and in the grand final and ha ha
water stop what a strategy coming out
from material Envy no one has ever done
that no one has ever done that in the
history of DOTA the now iconic Roshan
bait single-handedly made it s for the
captain of no tidehunter how did you
pitch that to your teammates like hey
guys we're gonna do this pretty strat it
requires one of us to die at the very
beginning so what happened is we play
the grand finals in not on a main stage
to game one and then Game two we had to
go to the main stage but we had like a
30 minute break so it was like what are
we gonna do guys we're down one game you
know we're playing as DG and so yeah we
just came up with a strategy get some
momentum you know into the game so you
actually came up with that fat on spot
yeah you didn't like to see like it was
a pub straddling anything like that
users just like no no we were actually
to start off we were trying to do a
level 1 rush but then we came up
that's what went on but it wasn't the
only thing about that tournament that
propelled him into stardom s4 was
pioneering strategy and no tine hunter
were just out playing their opponent
geodes on the run still looking for this
track Hannah's coming one kill double
kill triple kill knocking out at four
who'll give him all via spinning it on
the way out it's already another kill
for blinka body block high school and
all team up Jule Bret break for those
hide hunter took a Christmas break but
s4 kept playing he participated in
beyond the summit's Fistful of tangos
1v1 tournament good evening ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls it is time for
something completely different that's
right
we are gonna try our heads at our first
ever 1v1 tournament it's called a
fistful of tangos if you don't get the
reference I suggest you do some Google
and you please second after a long
losers bracket run or he beat kuroky
Korek Sing Sing and syndrome cementing
his place as one of dota 2 'the best
young talents faking he's faking it he's
not actually going through the room what
a fake from s fault he pretended to be
going for the rune he was actually
waiting in the trees here incredible
play for s4 really smart play from him
he's gonna take the chewer victory s4
coming through the loser bracket taking
out sin during when the tournament
circuit restarted no tidehunter
continued to do well winning starladder
star series season 5 in April a bit of a
tent set up by no hunter inside the base
there they can actually he did they go
for the gg so they go at through the top
they might just go straight the GG
before that I call it but now they call
it TG
and are tied Hut's up they will take it
out just after that no tidehunter was
signed to alliance and the team went on
an absolute bling a crit and probably a
kill s floor diving LGD and the shadow
of their foul GG from chalet at the
Alliance are your g1 league season five
champion both seven got a sprout himself
in says four says I don't like trees
once again here Jeff that's four in a
row and ultra kill at 16 minutes oh my
god face it's on it's dropping down
1,000 1,000 1,000 GG well played is ko
fighting it does freaking face race with
so much damage and now ball off dives in
picks off syndrome and this looks like
Megas come up in a second he pulled up
didn't even care about that now that
solo stuff GG is cold and Alliance they
will walk away with first place prize
$9,000 the team looked unstoppable and
Alliance they take it man are you
kidding me it's a perfect game the
perfect spotless pristine performance
hangs a goose egg on the opposition and
the great finals of a Dreamhack could
have this much momentum or you guys
really go me maybe where we need to or
Peking very early when it comes to this
kind of thing I think it's good if you
imagine being like a losing team I don't
think that would be feeling so good
going into a good problem to have I
guess yeah Alliance went 14 and oh and
ti3 scoring stage Alliance the team from
Sweden undefeated in the prelims then
moved on to drop just one game in the
upper bracket like I always imagined how
it would be for the players in the games
like what's the pressure
and stuff like that but now getting to
ti3 it's I don't know it's amazing but
not as Ben Sayer put together an
impressive run of their own and we're
slated to face off against alliance in
the grand finals ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the grand final in Game one
nabis puppy brought out several unique
picks but s4 stuck to the usual gameplay
and they ended up stomping Nobby three
dead no track kills for Navi and they're
not going to get any make it for Navi
down to 211 and then get a gg the
challenge was met with force that's Navi
took a quick game of their own puppy
stole my team died on our game they
don't even need the black hole this is
the most one-sided game that the
Alliance has lost in this entire
tournament despite the close series Navi
put Dendi on IO
in the middlee for Game three Hiroki
will be playing your support Rubik Dendi
has swapped back to his winnings to the
pick Navi had control of the early game
and Alliance were firmly shut down it
comes as for these bound buttock and cut
it off as well that's arm against the
fairies huh
anything fun except on initiation before
I was a rapier
with that na'vi were just one game away
from winning ti3 and the chance for a
majority of the roster to carve their
names on the aegis of champions twice
both teams opened Game four with stable
well-rounded mix but s4's ace came in
the final peg with Night Stalker and the
Night Stalker on the buttock flat swing
up lo de Bologna is still alive he's
still got a satanic my bonuses heads and
above well OH
Elias the Swedish may force a game five
with the Lions tying up the series to
two ti3 already broke new ground for a
TI grand final this is the first time in
ti history that were going to a game
number five creative drafts and ballsy
plays characterizes Harry but the best
was yet to come
it all comes down to this one more game
two million dollars on the table still
rochette stands this time Dendi wants to
go in while that's happening bat riders
back to the pit it's low there's no
black hole it's there a way to steal
this s4 looking to lead Roush's lo can
he grab it in time Dendi backs off bkb's
up on the back side funny fall buddy
now Brosius just with a sliver of HP if
Dendi gets this if he gets this they
might not be able to stop
[Applause]
Alliance took the first Aegis at 21
minutes installed the game waiting for
Roshan to resent gross dropping fast no
reaction from the light so they just
give this up they're still not committed
now they found that score he's the key
to their success of these fights and he
done sign he's got a fire back but it's
too late
Roche is dead puppy moving forward Aegis
is a Navi and now it's time to see what
they're really made of has game 5 neared
its end s4 showed up when it counted
most and delivered a clutch dream coil
giving alliance a chance to close it out
we'll get Claudius by back it's a
crystal made it down but the push comes
top it's a nice pick for Navi it's not
enough but it can't grow sure they can't
Roach they don't have enough damage they
don't have much PP he canceled defeat
cookie Bobby's not gonna be back in the
face he's got became me but no boots of
travel now if they go over the throne it
could be game Bunnings down a lion
I'm doing it they need a little more but
those two fall down at jeopardy
that's a glyph it could be their last
stand
then these back he's gonna try to focus
everybody but there's so much stuff but
there's no more clips available the end
of a half HP a cordage be a lion
surrounding per month maybe
they always supported this game in Korea
because I thought if they really
believed in going forward and they
really aim for it they you must have one
brother that could actually do it
s4 stood at the very peak of dota
watching him playing in ten feet make me
so probably I'm so good nothing could
hold us back you know and we didn't see
any struggles except in the grand files
but that's another sock he was a key
player in the most important game ever
played he was the man behind the million
dollar dream
[Applause]
after ti3 team started to catch up to
alliance na'vi got their revenge on
alliance in a 3-1 grand finals at
starladder season 7 their mother for
this tv's cold
Alliance ten fell out of MLG Columbus in
the crew stage and the team only managed
to pick up to land winds between ti3 and
ti4
they weren't a terrible team but they
were shell of their former selves
welcome to the international as 4/1 the
1v1 tournament at the I pour but it was
the only victory he's gonna man fight I
suppose about the boots he can chase
down Ferrari Ferraris gonna make a run
for s was gonna raise in two seconds
five gets the right look for areas for
the southern fight if mrs. booth racism
s4 gets the kill
he is your champion alliances returning
from ti3 as champions and s4 says I'll
start it off with a bang takes that 1v1
championship here in Seattle Alliance
went six and nine in the group stage
hide for 11 the decent gold in Tier
three probably they would do the same
thing in ti4 well he will take the
fortress and they will eliminate the
defending champions in the group stage
from the International 2014 who were
like trying too much to fix things in
the team
I can change Vince myself as a captain I
didn't feel like I was ready at that
point therefore I take a lot of
responsibility pride in the span of one
year Alliance went from unstoppable
world champions to also-rans s4 decided
to try his luck elsewhere he teamed up
with his longtime rival a legendary Navi
captain puppy to help found team
alongside fly big daddy no tail and
kuroky on the surface secret looks like
a dream team every player on the team
was one of the best in their position
however in their debut at starladder
season 10 they would get stomped by none
other than s former tumble now as for
outside of the base it looks like he'll
get click down there's only one left
it's fly he's scooting back to safety
and safety he'll find they'll turn their
sights on to puppy and
getting kicked off this is just a
massacre there you go GG well played and
alliance they just slap team secret
around and their debut 35 to 5 it is a
pretty one-sided performance here
syndrome eventually finding their
footing team secret would go on to close
out the calendar year by placing third
fourth at ESL one New York second at
starladder season 10 third of the summit
to 1st at xmg captain's draft and first
a dota pit league season 2 he's dead
5 acts status is not their last no BKB
Phobos and their GG is called in secret
are going to be your total pick season 2
winners over the holiday season the team
lost fly and no tail but replaced them
with artisans I maintaining their status
oh no Ichi they begin to crumble with a
G 13 minutes we're all done here
secret takes it Wow simply put secret or
incredible winning trophy after trophy
in the lead up to TI 5 tree the by
becomes everybody around here with PPD
top in the end he gets the area not easy
[Music]
that makes four straight land wins 14
secret for land wins in 2015 the most of
any team and I think you put it
absolutely perfectly man I don't care
what team you root for you have to root
for that glint brand of dota the team
secret play tonight what an impressive
incredible historic performance to take
home the ESL pride but it all fell apart
he's gonna be dropping here to god she
just fully commits for this far towards
out for two minutes
[Applause]
eliminated the fan favorites of this
tournament secret placed second in their
group with a 4-3 and OH record but fell
in the bracket losing two oh two eHome
and 2-1 convert us pro for all his hard
work
s4 had another mediocre TI performance
on his record it wasn't terrible but it
wasn't a winner and that's the level guy
outs home team secret they have been
eliminated and who finished 7th 8th that
means a national tooth
and 15 one of the biggest shock waves in
dota 2 history destiny team secret
collapsed after the loss puppy was the
only player who stuck with the org and
rebuilt its roster by himself for his
part as for went back to Alliance and
over the course of the year they rebuilt
their ti3 winning squad the team failed
to put together any significant wins
after ti but in December they picked up
a massive world cyber arena that's the
game right there there's no way to come
back from this for LGD Alliance will
take out the grand final three games in
- they won the first - they played the
hog rider Alliance will take the victory
they will take the tournament they take
WCA congratulations look at the reaction
unbelievable I know they're doing this
they leave s4 s horses like what's going
on let me die let me die in just a few
weeks later at starladder i-league
season 1 the old Alliance swept
ti5 champions Evil Geniuses in the
finals to take first place the board's
going buddy critical damage Elijah stack
away and they rotate on the top the
meges are coming out and GG things
started looking up for the old heroes
with a nostalgic wave didn't last fall a
whines didn't find any more wins that
year they attended every valve major and
qualified for ti6 but were swept out of
the bracket stage by eHome and fnatic GG
well played fnatic have done it they
will stop
the 2-0 victory over Alliance
eliminating them from the International
2016 while s4 was struggling some of his
old secret teammates had formed og s4
joined reuniting with fly and no tail
and switched to the offline at the spot
in Terrence being so long the
fortifications already backed up all
that votes not the rocket previous four
gave him the perfect vision the trainee
already kind of played this role before
where he would be the tempered
controller and the guy making things
happen so it kind of fits for him to go
to DA flame og looked good as the season
started but they came into their own at
the Boston major where s4 won his first
ever
smash and Gigi's good
Carano series 4s for a player who seemed
past his prime
oh gee represented a shot at redemption
s4 shifted to the hall playing on and
relatively new bid on the scene but the
court seems fly in those he'll have
deceived countless championships and og
kept up their momentum by taking first
place at the key of me they come Sammy
jump ball cats out though the rock will
drop I just aren't half the damage to
repel RG J Jay King will be claimed for
time dargah turn major winners here at
Kiev s4 found Redemption on og he found
a team that was what secret was supposed
to be
Oh G placed 7th 8th at CI that year and
while they looked strong since the team
isn't favored to win TI 8 but in dota 2
TI is just about the only tournament
that matters their important events
outside of TI but none can match its
prestige none have its multi-million
dollar prize pool none can award you the
ages and the title of best in the world
an s4 wanted to be known as the best he
knows what it means what it feels like
to stand at the top and he won't rest
until he's felt it again no I get it
when he comes into the room - it's like
he's a TI winner and then all the girls
just go there thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button